rather give you all of the theory to
begin with this is one of those contents
words best understood right let's have a
look at the example and let's see what
happens okay so here is a function that
I want us to investigate it's a fairly
simple function it's a function which we
can know a lot about without knowing any
calculus okay it's a cubic it's a cubic
so we can start to draw this thing based
on if we can factorize it that's how we
usually important polynomials so it's a
very easy cooking what can I do to stop
that rising I can take a factor of X out
and that leaves me with x squared take
away 6x plus 9 that's nice because
what's left in there is a perfect square
it's a quadratic and it's not just any
quadratic it's a perfect square so what
I've got now is X outside of X take away
3 or square ok great so now that I know
that I already have a great idea of what
this looks like okay I know that cubic
I'm expecting three roots I've got one
here but then I have two roots on the
same spot at three okay now what is what
is that not life well don't don't draw
this just yet don't try this just yet
normally at this point all you would be
able to do is to say okay I've got a
zero
and I've got a root at one two three
okay and if it's there to roots there
being that this is a cubic with what's
the leading coefficient it's one so it's
morning it's positive it is the
employment mean that I'm looking at so
therefore for very large values of X
what happens to Y also very large right
also very large and important very much
positive okay because you guys know a
cubic you can sort of start the bottom
and go to the top or any do the reverse
you can start at the top and go to the
bottom we're looking at category one
here right so roughly speaking this is
the same I'm expecting okay roughly
speaking and that's all you'd be
expected to do at the moment
okay however now we know this derivative
stuff right and so we can know
or about the geometry of this thing in
particular we're on earth is that right
what's that called again what's that's a
stationary point I can find where that
it is very easily by going to the next
derivative so let's just quickly do that
if this is y let's compute the first
derivative thank you thank you Oh being
that I've factorized it the reason why
our factorized we've serve and I could
get a picture of it okay but to
differentiate probably easiest to go
back to the original one right like I
don't need chain of products really
doing that so differentiate for me good
okay
again something which is relatively easy
to factorize so I'm going to take out a
factor of 3 maybe maybe this guy and
what can we do with this
fantastic so this is negative 1 negative
3 or I really know well it doesn't
matter which alright ok ok
yeah just pause for a second right
remember that we were drawing some
questions about some conclusions about
where the roots were based on where the
zeros of this are okay by the way if you
remember that's similar tician some
language that i've talked about before
zeros are values that make this thing
zero okay so this thing I can't say I'm
lucky looking for the solution to this
the solution to this are every single
point on the line okay but the zero is
our it collides with the x axis so the
zero is here we're at zero and three so
that was where my intercept up this has
different zeros well one of them is the
same one of the series of this guy one
and three okay now these two correspond
to in two sets morning but two
stationary points right this is where
this the first would be zero okay so
these on my stationary points okay now
you can start to see let's notice a
couple of things right again this is my
rock drone we get into a proper one
actually very very shortly but you can
see like I just roughly did that right i
roughly did it and you'll notice where I
put my station in point just when I did
my you know free hand curve is I put
that roughly halfway between and that's
not a bad guess to make and if you did
that in like interview ten the start of
year 11 that would be fine but now we
know that's not where it is at all
it is not halfway at all okay this is a
cubic you don't get the same kind of
symmetry you get with a parabola with
the the stationary point is right in the
middle of the theme it's actually going
to be over here in one I think we have
enough information to graph this thing
properly now okay so here's I'm gonna
ask you to do on your page and we're
gonna use the whole take graph that's
tricky I'm also sorry we're going to
function the graph that's three in a
minute because that's what we're
focusing on we're going to get the
second derivative as well and I want to
compare all of them geometrically so
would you draw with me three sets
the taxis or one on top of each other
that's actually really important okay
now this time work we're not focusing on
the formality of stuff so normally I
would set this out a bit neater
but we just try to get a picture in it
in a sort of quick and dirty fashion
okay so in some ways by the way what
we're doing right now is if the question
were simply sketch and they said showing
all features and they were like you know
three or four months on this thing okay
the emphasis is not on this working but
on what my final result will be but
obviously I'm gonna put some working
down okay but I'm not you know how we've
been writing a lot of stuff when we're
going to a question to buy the station
points determine their nature and so on
that is not the focus for this question
the focus of this question is the
picture okay so that's what I'm doing at
the load now I already know and this
time I'm gonna do it properly I'm a
measuring out over one two three so
there are my two intercepts now I found
the X values for stationary points right
I rather uncommon sedately I've noticed
that one of the stationary points is
also one of the groups okay so I don't
need to find the coordinates of that I
already know where it is but I don't
know up and down I don't know where this
stationary point the x equals once they
should point I don't know where it is so
how do I find its location something
fantastic very good just another reason
why it's important why you'd write y
equals this and dy DX equals that
so you don't confuse where am I putting
this thing again I'm looking for a white
cordial so that's why I'm gonna put it
in here
so the trackers when x equals 1 y equals
I'm going to buy straight substitution
one take away six plus nine which is
okay so now I have a y coordinate so
that tells me that this stationary point
here is actually 1 comma 4 and this 1 is
3 comma 0 okay that's enough for me
that's enough for us to draw this let's
plot this this time being that I am I
don't actually need to worry too much
about the up/down of this because you'll
notice my y-intercepts my actual
y-intercept is 0 okay now how do I
notice for example up here there's a
plus 1 he it'll be the same thing just
moved up one okay if I made this
x-intercept one I really have to be
careful and pay attention if this next
intercept would be at a particular point
that scales might've got it consistent
vertically but I don't have any other
points to be consistent with vertically
here anyway so I'm just going to put it
wherever I want ok that's gonna be a
stationary point right so just as a
little aid for myself I'm gonna put a
horizontal line there because that's
what it should do when it gets there
that's a guide for me to make sure as I
draw it up it's gonna behave in the way
that I want and I already knew ago
station you point there ok and from here
it's joined adults
okay I did all right